Let's look at the solution
to our MSI access quiz.
We have two cores with private caches
and MSI coherence, initially block
access in Memory, which means that it's
really invalid in both of the caches.
After we read X and C1s cache,
C1s cache with transition this block
from I to S, the shared state.
Because this was a read we
move to the shared state.
Even though it is not really shared,
this is our way of saying basically that
the block is clean, and
that we only want to read it.
In C2s cache it stay invalid.
When C2 then does a read, it also
gets the block in the shared state.
And if we snoop a read
request in the shared state,
we stay in the shared state.
So finally when C1 writes to X, because
it has a block in the shared state,
it needs to send an invalidation out.
That results in C2 moving
the block to the invalid state.
It can no longer be read until
we get the new copy from C1,
and C1 after writing has
the block in the modified state.